we started it in june
we said take the month of july off
facebook we told companies don't
advertise on facebook for the month of
july and when we started the campaign we
had we didn't have a single company
lined up and it was very audacious
three weeks later we had over 1100
companies the biggest brands in the
world incredible coca-cola mcdonald's so
why were they so deceptive do you think
what like i'll tell you exactly why
because we gave them examples of like
white supremacist and anti-semitic and
racist content on facebook like flighted
against their ads yeah that's pretty
convincing so here's an amazon ad you
know next to a just like a bloody truck
that says let's go get the next george
floyd or
here's a salesforce ad or a verizon ad
and so on and so forth
and you put that out there and howard
schultz says i don't want starbucks
advertising alongside the nazis but
that's what facebook was doing
and you know like i've talked to them
many times i had a conversation once
with mark and he said
around all of this i think maybe that's
in the book and he said you know
jonathan a few years ago
all of the hate content on facebook was
user reported he said to me today 88
is is caught by our ai before users even
see it so i think we're doing pretty
good
and i was and i said okay well i used to
be an executive at starbucks we didn't
get to say 88 of our coffee doesn't have
poison in it so we think we're doing
pretty good
[Music]
[Music]
this week on ford the ceo of the
anti-defamation league and author of the
new book it could happen here jonathan
greenblatt joins us
[Music]
it is my pleasure to welcome to the ford
podcast the ceo of the anti-defamation
league and the author of the new book it
could happen here my friend john
greenblatt jonathan welcome thank you
for having me andrew uh well
congratulations on this book
uh it's an achievement it's frightening
uh i think most americans unfortunately
sense that it could happen here yeah
what prompted you to take
uh the time to write this book
well i guess i could tell the story
about the book sort of by stepping back
so i've been the ceo of adl for about
six and a half years give or take
but i'm the come to this work as the
grandson of a holocaust survivor from
germany
and my grandfather my great grandfather
fought in the first world war germany
was the only country that my family ever
knew
and
you know before the rise of the third
reich they never would have guessed
that
again the only country that they knew
would one day turn on them regard them
as enemies of the state destroy
everything that they ever loved
slaughter almost their entire network of
family and friends
and forced them to come my grandfather
everyone else died come to the united
states as he did as a refugee and that
one day i mean when he was a young man
he couldn't have guessed that his
grandchildren me and my brother and my
cousins would be born in america never
and i come to this work as the husband
of a political refugee from iran
and you know my wife and her family came
here when she was 19 like in 1989 maybe
maybe 18 but the point is that
you know iran was the only country they
ever knew
and before the rise of you know the
islamic republic and khamenei's fascism
they never would have guessed that one
day the country would regard them as
enemies of the state destroy everything
that they ever loved and force them to
come to flee and come to this country as
refugees i mean my father-in-law never
would have guessed that my kids and my
nieces and nephews that his
grandchildren were born in america so i
wrote this book because my own history
tells us
and you know every you know the world
lets us know reminds us that it could
happen here and if you and i andrew want
our grandchildren to be born in this
country we've got to fight for what we
have
and we're foolish to think that
democracy is preordained
we're foolish to think that we're
somehow immune
not just from intolerance but from the
kind of catastrophes we're seeing play
out around the world
and you know we got to be in it to win
it we got to do something and the
subtitle of your book is why america is
tipping from hate to the unthinkable and
how we can stop it i have to say my
friend i think you might have the
hardest job there is
oh and i say this because
uh you and i both started and founded
non-profits
nonprofits
this is a different kind of non-profit i
mean the anti-defamation league is the
most
prominent anti-hate organization with a
storied history but i feel like it means
that you are on the front lines all of
the time yeah that anytime there's
any kind of episode
uh
unfortunately
ranging from all the way from a mass
casualty event or a shooting to someone
making a misstatement that can be
construed as hateful you all get called
and i have to imagine that uh it it must
be like you are being bombarded by
uh these kind of experiences all the
time
yeah i mean it's fair to say it's
definitely a complicated job i mean i
think look the adl is an institution as
you said it's actually the oldest
anti-aid organization in the country was
founded in 1913. so i feel a great deal
of responsibility when i think about the
legacy that i'm responsible for as
someone who's you said like he's been an
entrepreneur and been an innovator now
i'm in charge of this entity
and it feels like very pretentious and
really you know a burden
and you're right i mean from like
from whoopi goldberg to pittsburgh
right like
there is a constant you know set of
events that force the adl to show up and
to speak out and so part of the job is
calibrating and understanding
when do you speak out and when is it a
tweet
versus a full-on statement versus you
know an advocacy campaign
uh
like how do you
you have to learn how to
sort of calibrate appropriate to the
offense
and how to put things in some
perspective because i will say i mean
like the stuff is happening you said
every single day and not just to jews to
asian americans to african-americans to
other minority groups and so
it's it's you i do the job day-to-day
yeah you must have a very very
strong mind i would say or heart or
spirit because
uh having that as your
day-to-day responsibility i mean it's
something that not many people could
could work through
on a daily basis and at the end of your
book you actually say
uh that when you were offered this role
it was either this or it seemed like it
was head to the west coast and return to
entrepreneurship yeah well i had an
opportunity you know when i
so basically to step back because you
were saying i have been an entrepreneur
i've been in business a long time
and i was working in private equity when
i got recruited to work in the the white
house to run the office of social
innovation
the plan the deal that i cut with my
wife as we do it for a few years then
we'd go back to california
and i was going to go either start a
fund or run a fund and i was in
negotiation with a big firm to do that
i got this offer that i took this job um
there you go
but look like i like you like i believe
in public service and i felt like a call
to service and it felt like something
that mattered
and in all honesty i thought i'd do it
for a few years
and then i would resume my life in
business
and then the week that i started on the
job was the same week that donald trump
announced his candidacy wow so it was
like the wheels came off
well you and i met when you were at the
white house as the director of the
office of social innovation and civic
participation before that for people
listening to this at home
jonathan founded ethos water which is
when you go to starbucks you know that
really really good-looking bottle yeah
and you know that uh if you buy that
water uh
a portion go to
a good cause yeah uh so you and i met
back uh when you were and i remember
walking in and meeting you and saying
like oh wow the office of social
innovation i had started a nonprofit
venture of america so of course i
thought maybe i can get some money out
of the government
[Laughter]
which did not happen but we became fast
friends uh
so talk about your arc because you had a
wide-ranging career you kind of dipped
in and out of public service you were in
the clinton white house you were back in
the business world and they managed to
rope you back in yeah
yeah i mean i think you know i've always
been motivated by
since i was in college by wanting to
change the world which sounds a bit kind
of glib or naive but
that was always sort of my true north so
when i was graduating or when i
graduated from tufts i went and joined
the clinton campaign and moved to
arkansas and worked for governor clinton
in little rock wow well and then and
then he won which you know i didn't
think he was going to win at the time
you're like i'm a genius i don't know
about that
but then i end up going up to dc and
doing international economics for five
and a half years like applied
microeconomic policy with an emphasis on
international trade and
uh investment in emerging markets
and that was great and it was fun um did
that take you all over the world
all over particularly it was like a
remarkable time so like the mid 90s
you had the european kind of community
becoming the european union
you had you know germany literally
politically reunified in in the year
1990
and so you had this remarkable moment
where as in 92 as again the european
union really came together
and moved to becoming an economic entity
it was remarkable you had nafta and the
emergence of free trade in the western
hemisphere and mercosur which was is a
trading block of argentino brazil and
chile
uh and then there was a movement toward
a free trade agreement of the americas
you had apec came online i mean you know
china sounds like you were attending a
lot of conferences a lot
i've been a lot of like done trade
negotiations you know i worked on uh
apec as asean was coming into the fore
right which is the association of
southeast asian nations which was an
economic block it was seven countries
now i think it's 10 or 11 countries
uh
and
as uh china was successing
or hong kong was coming out of you know
as a british protectorate yeah and china
was coming into we were talking about
were we talking about this before about
china getting most favored nation status
and joining the wto the in fact i
remember when the gat the joke given to
tariffs and trades became the world
trade organization so i worked at the
nexus of all this really interesting
stuff
well yeah it sounds like you were
right there at the forefront when the
world was kind of knitting itself
together into this world order
um and now you and i were talking but
before we sat down about how it seems
like that order is coming apart
it's reversing itself
you talked about the
dramatic impact of sanctions on
russia that many people in america
probably don't appreciate what that
actually means day-to-day in the russian
economy oh yeah i mean so it's
interesting to your point like i think
we all believed there was this kind of
gravitational
force called globalization that was
inevitably drawing us together
the reality is it globalization isn't an
outcome it's an intention and it
requires like will and work and it can
be reversed as we're seeing so we're
talking about economic sanctions like
economic sanctions are a kind of warfare
and it may be invisible and you don't
see it in midtown manhattan but in
russia you know the value of the ruble
has basically
dropped to almost zero they can't get
any hard currency and because russia's
been cut off now from western trade
flows they have like 600 billion in
reserves
around the world that they can't get
their hands on and so the value of
russian bonds is also going to plummet
to zero which is going to impact all
these big companies and it'll have
ripple effects on emerging markets
around the world it's going to be harder
for those countries in southeast asia in
south america latin america more broadly
to get access to capital two i mean
frankly emerging markets are probably
pretty cheap right now
you could buy it at quite a discount but
i think it's going to have all these
impacts and so for ordinary russians
not only are there boys being sent to
fight in a war that they don't
understand because they all have family
and friends
yeah nothing to do with suddenly their
purchasing power is de minimis and so
that's going to create all kinds of
unintended consequences i mean just wait
putin is being backed into whether we we
might not be flying bombers into
ukrainian airspace
but believe me we are backing him into a
corner
and it'll be interesting and maybe a
little bit scary to see how he responds
well we we all hope that
uh reason prevails and peace returns i
mean the goal of these sanctions is to
elevate the pressure to a point where it
feels like uh he'll come to the table um
but you're right that i mean that that's
uncertain i i assumed putin was too
rational an actor to engage in this sort
of aggression so so now like this is the
reality right so
by our means by are like western
standards by art from our american kind
of calculus it's irrational but in his
mind who's aspiring to recreate like a
czarist imperial
kind of moment he's acting rationally
and he's willing to sacrifice those
soldiers and you know risk his economy
to achieve this imperial ambition so
this is you know one of the things that
i think we in the united states were all
very sort of solipsistic and we see
things that through our own story and
our own image but the reality is
is that
we need to take these sort of tyrants at
their word we think they're not
irrational but in their mind they're
actually being highly rational so when
putin says he believes in a greater
russia
when khamenei says
he wants to annihilate the jewish state
you know when she says like there is one
china like
they mean it and we need to listen to
them and we need to reimagine kind of
our political calculus in light of what
they're telling us
winter is finally ending and the sun is
starting to peek out but that does not
mean that we are all feeling 100
it has been a very very tough time and
sometimes we need some help it's why i
am proud to be sponsored by better help
which is going to get you the help that
you need via online therapy with a
professional not someone who doesn't
know what they're doing or your friend
who just has to put up with it but an
on-call
online therapist that will meet you when
you want how you want totally
confidential i am pumped for people to
be able to get this help it's more
affordable you can be matched with a
therapist in under 48 hours over 2
million people have used better help
online therapy to take charge of their
mental health and if this describes you
and i got to say it describes most of us
you should probably at least check out
betterhelp this podcast is sponsored by
betterhelp and forward listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
yang that's b e t t
e r h e l p
dot com slash yang mental health is
health people and you can take care of
yourself better with betterhelp.com
[Music]
so you spend the 90s uh helping
establish this uh
world
order uh that's fine that's portrayed
that's now falling so well done jonathan
we yeah i mean someone had to build it
right um you returned to the business
world for i did that
i got an mba i mean i wanted to change
the world but then you know there was
gridlock in washington and i wanted to
go i saw businesses the front was the
front line yep so i got an mba at
kellogg at northwestern and then went to
be part of the internet and i joined a
little pre-ipo
company called realtor.com yeah which
ended up being going public and being
very big i was like the
assistant junior
associate product manager i was just
north of the receptionist
uh but i learned how to build software
products how to manage teams of
engineers
and that's what i did and so i ended up
after a few years running the consumer
products division of the company and you
know responsible for a whole line of
products but i missed public service so
my roommate from kellogg this guy named
peter thumb had this idea to create a
company ethos water which was bottled
water at the time was a 15 billion
dollar category it's really starting to
grow in the united states
and yet there were a billion people who
lack clean drinking water said it was
could you create a bottled water that
would use part of its profits to help
children around the world you're one of
the og social entrepreneurs before it
was cool
well it's it's uh nice to see you it's
true that's accurate i mean when we this
word social entrepreneur this guy named
bill drayton from ashoka and jackie
jacqueline novogratz kind of down the
street here who talked about it but a
few others did very few they weren't
classes at business schools there
weren't
you know there was no bee lab there was
none of this whole movement we have
today
but we took look we took our inspiration
from people like ben cohen and jerry
greenfield and gary hirschberg and
gordon anita roddick and yvonne chennard
these extr who created like patagonia
and body shop and stonyfield and ben and
jerry's respectively uh because there
was that generation then there was we
were like part of the second generation
i would say with people like um jeffrey
hollander from seventh generation or
seth goldman from honesty this guy dan
lubetsky
this company
himself who's uh one of our mutual
friends
you know i tell a story about meeting
him in the white house and then he asks
us uh hey anyone hungry and someone says
yes and then he busts his jacket open
and he has kind bars all in the lining
like i called it like batman
utility belt isn't that funny yeah i
mean he's always an entrepreneur so he's
got the hustle man he's got the hustle
so and then the third generation of
those entrepreneurs i think are people
like um
you know neil blumenthal and the guys
from warby parker
or blake and the guy from toms and and
the guys from bonobos who have done a
really smart job
again i think peter and i had this
innovation
you know link consumption and college
you buy the water you get the water and
then then blake did it with you buy the
shoes someone gets shoes or you buy the
socks someone gets the socks and so on
and i think that's a marvelous model so
ethos ends up uh getting acquired by
starbucks we sold it to starbucks yeah
and then i worked there running the
bottle water business so just random
inside we want to discuss this so howard
schultz runs for president or has an
exploratory committee yeah for 2020.
yeah um
did you advise on that were you around
the team for any of that i did not so
i've kept in touch with howard
and i knew look like howard has been
like i so i learned so much from him it
was such a i have such gratitude having
a chance to work for him
uh but this is a long time coming i mean
if you looked at even starbucks they
they had a domestic policy agenda they
supported veterans they supported boys
young men of color health healthcare to
all their employees they did they do
with arizona state university you know
free education college education for
starbucks partners or baristas so they
like from education to veterans to
healthcare it was remarkable
and he's got so much passion and so much
energy
um you know and a lot of hubris but i
say that
with you know i say that as a compliment
because to build a business like you did
you need to have confidence to either
build a company like starbucks or run
for president you know something about
that
he's one of those two i don't know i
know something about um so
so they got you back into uh public
service you had a really plum job i
thought like in terms of cool jobs in
the administration uh uh social
innovation civic participation yeah one
of the things you write about in your
book that i'm passionate about
is a call to national service yes it
could potentially help depolarize people
absolutely see each other as like look
like you know we live a little bit
differently but you're more or less just
like me um so you were part of an office
that was helping to drive various
organizations what do we need to do to
actually uh re-establish national
service look i just you know i have
actually never heard that phrase before
but it's right
depolarization
i believe in that and service is a
strategy to achieve that and yes
um
you know it's interesting i believe
president biden and his like the build
back better bill which
i think is now doa and they're trying to
break it up but he had dollars in there
like
16 billion to create a climate
a climate core of some kind look the
idea like young people like you at one
time like me at one time they all want
to talk about why didn't you say that
long time ago but like they want to
change the world and i think
the the folks who are farther along
should help them and give them the help
create the space give them the lane to
do that and national service is a way
that it can be done
and so i just think there's something
incredibly powerful but it's going to
take
funding so that young people can
actually earn a living or
earn a little bit if you will
and it's going to take creating the
space to give them the opportunities
whether it's again in education or
healthcare or with veterans et cetera to
do good in our communities well the
reason i ask is that i've been part of
gatherings where they talked about
national services everyone's like yeah
yeah yeah let's do it uh but but people
look at it and think well in order to do
it at scale you pretty much need the
government because you do the dollars
add up pretty quick
yeah like the the previous cost of the
stipend
was i think actually today it's about 16
500 meaning the government pays young
people
an annual salary of sorts of 16 five and
so the kids who do national service man
they're not like staying at the uh you
know holla at the ritz even the holiday
inn express they're sleeping on cots in
the basement of the church totally
they're not they're not flying united
premium like they're driving 15 people
in a 12-person van yeah and
again they're not eaten you know at some
fancy sushi restaurant they're eating
ramen noodles
but what's sustaining them and
nourishing them is the act of building
community it's amazing but it requires
money and it requires both sides you
know i think some people on the right
still see national service as like a
democratic
bill clinton
there are some that's odd there are some
and i think there's some on the left
who also like want them to do very
specific things so but the best what i
mean by that is there's a tradition of
service like in our military yeah that's
derided by some on the left and by the
way you know faith communities have
amazing churches of service like that's
true
oh yeah like the church of latter-day
saints if you've ever met anyone who's a
self-identified mormon their commitment
to service is unbelievable
so i think the left needs to acknowledge
the power of like faith-based service
and military service and the right needs
to see the power the non-political
nature of service of all kinds
you know it's interesting you raised
this because i actually hadn't
encountered resistance to national
service uh from the left but as you say
this so one thing i did encounter and
this is just a story i'll share
is that um i had started an anti-heat
campaign and i wanted to use the
american flag as part of it and there
was resistance among people
around using the american flag and i was
like guys if we don't use the flag
uh then we lose you know it's like if if
you let certain like let's say a certain
party uh own the flag like
that's bananas uh it was an anti-asian
hate campaign um and so it was all
americans and was like look asians are
american like you know like let's
denote that in some way and then there
was resistance to using the american
flag and i was like how else can you say
that asians are americans or asian
americans are americans without some
without the flag like i just didn't see
any way to do it this is crazy so i was
actually just having conversation with
someone a few days ago and i said you
know i believe in american
exceptionalism
because i do i mean i think america is
so different than other nations before
us and we're an idea
and you know there are other countries
who are
bound up and powerful ideas like france
or china or israel or others but what's
so powerful about america is this idea
that we're
we are not although there are indigenous
americans we should talk about the way
that they were treated and of course the
economy was built on the backs of
enslaved africans and that's a that's a
sin for which we are still paying
and yet the power of america is the
acknowledgment of our imperfections the
idea that all of us as immigrants or
refugees or whatever the case or former
slaves can come together as one and so
i think that's inspiring
and the people who would say that the
american flag
is somehow a political symbol yeah yeah
just don't
get it at all
like i'm sorry
what hope do we have
if we think that like the the founding
national symbol is somehow a problem
that that was my stance as well so i you
know i it's but that was one of the
encounters i had was like huh like
people really see this a bit differently
and i i think that um i think part of it
is
uh age really you know like there are
people that are a bit younger than you
and i who might have like a slightly
different
framing of it
[Music]
there's not that much that unites people
nowadays but you know one thing just
about all of us have in common we love
to sleep we love to curl into bed and
get some shut eye and it's important
what the heck we are sleeping on it's
one reason why i am pumped to be
sponsored by helix sleep where they can
personalize a mattress just for you
soft medium firm do you sleep on your
stomach do you sleep on your side you
can go to helixleep.com and take a quiz
and then they will send you a mattress
taylor made for you it's 2022 you can
have it the way you want it and it's not
just me helix was awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2020 by gq
and wired magazine just go to
helixsleep.com take their two-minute
sleep quiz and they'll match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life you can try
it out for a hundred nights risk free
that's right you can sleep on something
for 99 nights and then return it it
would be weird i don't recommend it but
you can do it helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
yang helixsleep.com
[Music]
so
after you leave the obama white house
yeah they managed to rope you into uh
not proper i mean it's incredibly
important
for sure um to become the ceo of the
anti-defamation league yeah and then
trump runs for office around that time
um from your book uh it seems that
there's been a dramatic worsening
of uh all sorts of episodes of hate
whether it's measured in terms of speech
language social media posting all the
way up through
uh violence and militias
yeah i mean then the data doesn't lie i
mean so just take anti-semitism which so
often is considered the canary in the
coal mine like it's a harbinger of much
of equally and even more destructive
forms of hate you know anti-semitic
incidents from 2015 to 2020 have left
about 114 percent and i know this
because at adl we track anti-semitic
incidents yes we have 25 field offices
and we're tracking acts of not just
violence and vandalism which the police
also monitor but acts of harassment
right and bias which might not catch the
attention of law enforcement so a kid is
bullied at school you know an elderly
person is yelled at on the street like
we get all those calls our staff
investigated over 9 600 incidents in
2021 we have 400 full-time employees
doing this work
and so
just the number of raw incidents is way
up and by the way again like as kind of
we were alluding to before
there's no question that right-wing
extremism is driving a great deal of
this i mean the number of anti-semitic
incidents like correlated directly to
the trump years just like it or not it
just did right the numbers left up in
the second half of 2016
once he won the nomination and like
after election day andrew it was like a
straight line up terrible and and yet at
the same time you know it's not like
either side of the spectrum has a
monopoly immorality like we saw here in
new york in midtown last may
this spike in anti-jewish hate around
the fighting in gaza
where
jewish people who were guilty of the
crime of like wearing a keeper in public
or you know look you know
being orthodox like wearing a black hat
we saw people beating up in broad
daylight in times square we saw people
assaulted like in other parts of midtown
manhattan we saw people attacked in
brooklyn oh and by the way in los
angeles and in southern
florida and in las vegas and in chicago
and in all these places the attacker
didn't say you know what's your opinion
on the two-state solution or are you a
quote-unquote zionist like the people
were identified as jews and that made
them targets and the people who are
beating them up andrew to be crystal
clear they weren't the assailants
weren't wearing maga hats
they were they were wearing like
palestinian kefias and in in times
square a guy was attacked and hit with a
flagpole
you know and it wasn't like a trump 2024
flag it was like a palestinian flag now
i say this is someone who believes in a
two-state solution i say this is someone
who thinks
zionism and palestinian nationalism must
coexist and we need dignity and equality
and safety and security for israelis and
palestinians in two states but it's
undeniable
to
or undeniable is the wrong word but it's
impossible to ignore the animus that's
directed not against just the jewish
state but all jewish people clearly
there's
it's just hatred if you're attacking
someone that's on the street for
uh nothing other than their faith uh
their appearance yeah i mean look it's
interesting i'm thinking about again you
were talking prior about starting this
organization the fight you know aapi
hate like you might not like the way
beijing is treating the uyghurs or you
may have questions about you know what
happens to their tennis stars or
democracy activists in hong kong but
that isn't an excuse to beat up elderly
asian american people in queens
or or to assault like a elderly thai man
in san francisco and kill him or to
shoot women in atlanta like no stop aapi
hate just like we should stop
anti-semitism
uh period full stop
i'm going to share
uh some stories of my upbringing so i
grew up in a predominantly white town i
was one of the only asian kids there
maybe two jewish kids
uh and we both got picked on uh a lot
though i will say that the jewish kid
got it worse
and i didn't realize it because i was
quite young right um so i i would get
[ __ ] [ __ ] you know uh like
go back to china that sort of thing not
great obviously you're like a 12 13 year
old and but the jewish kid
they tried to
cut a swastika out of a plastic tray to
give to him like it was like another
level right um and again did not
appreciate it because at the time i was
like 12 13
um 14 but you said something earlier
about how jews are the canary in the
coal mine yeah it seems like when you
have an environment that's conducive to
hate for whatever reason that like that
the energy around anti-semitism
is
always higher or elevated and jews are
the single biggest victims of
like oppression and even genocide
internationally there's something where
there's a reason why the adl frankly
like you know
it was founded as a jewish organization
um but then those things tend to cascade
to other groups i'm just gonna again use
my you know intermediate school example
as like the jewish kid had it
the worst yeah and then there there are
others of us that got versions of it
that was like less virulent but still
uh nasty and i feel like
you know that that's true
uh
societally
yeah look i think you know for 2000
years the jews lived in exile
the state of israel's founding
withstanding for two thousand years the
jews lived in exile outside you know
their ancestral home in the middle east
they lived in europe the latin america
they lived in the middle east
and wherever they went they were the
other
they had their own you know they didn't
adopt christianity they didn't adopt
islam so they had their own religion
with their own way of praying in their
own language and their own customs and
they were i think we would use the term
today otherwise
right they were marginalized they were
typically not allowed to live you know
whether it was the church or the crown
or the mosque they weren't allowed to
live where the rest of the community
lived they weren't allowed to work the
professional dress community worked it
and when things went wrong and they
always did especially before like the
advent of the age of reason and the
enlightenment the age of reason when an
understanding of kind of the scientific
method and the things we take for
granted today
when like there was a bubonic plague
or there was a weather system or there
was some other disease or whatnot
they blamed the jew i mean they always
thought that it was the jew for not
accepting christ or not accepting allah
or
for
who knows what and so the jew made a
convenient because there were minorities
of jews all over they were a constant
convenience scapegoat
but as you were kind of just mentioning
i think
you know anti-semitism starts with the
jews it never ends with the jews
and that lesson that you can't scapegoat
somebody that you can otherwise them
it's easy to do with the jews then it
becomes easy to apply to others
so i think that you know it's
interesting the adl so the adl i'll tell
you in 30 seconds the adl was founded in
1913 around the time that a jewish man
was lynched he was falsely accused man
named leo frank he went from new york
down to atlanta to manage a family
business a young girl was found killed
on the property they immediately blamed
the jew
now keep in mind this happened at a time
when jews weren't allowed to work in
many professions
they couldn't get treatment at many you
know like healthcare facilities the
reason why you have all these hospitals
named like beth israel or cedar sinai
because the jews started their own
medical institutions they couldn't get
treatment in other places
they couldn't attend many universities
quotas kept them out couldn't live they
were restrictive housing covenants
prevented them from living in many
places so they faced what we would call
like in our parlance you know structural
discrimination or structural racism
and this jewish man is accused falsely
accused of a crime i mean he didn't
commit it he wasn't there nonetheless
falsely accused wrongfully convicted and
sentenced to to death
the governor of georgia at the time
because he didn't have due process
intervened and commuted his sentence to
life imprisonment and the mob was so
enraged by that act of leniency they
tore leo frank from his jail cell and
they hung him from a tree awful and
while the body is still hanging from the
rope you know the whole town gathers and
holds a picnic you know underneath the
corpse
and they take pictures
uh they take photographs and turn the
pictures into postcards and give them
out of souvenirs
wow it's inhuman you can still see leo
frank postcards all over the internet
there's all still out there so in that
moment a group of jews get together and
say we need to actually do something
about this they create this group the
anti-defamation league
and what's
they write like they write a charter we
would call it a manifesto
and in it are the words that they wrote
1913 not recently that we still use
today as our mission statement that its
purpose is to quote stop the defamation
of the jewish people
and secure justice and fair treatment to
all
so what's so interesting about that
is a hundred some odd years ago the jews
the united states were
weak and vulnerable they didn't have you
know social standing or economic
resources or kind of political influence
like their future was very uncertain
but what they realized was this idea
that we're talking about
that in order to in order to fight for
the jewish people you also had to fight
for all people and that only when all
people were saved could jews also be
safe i mean we're the only group out
there of our vintage that has this to
use a
term that's in vogue with the kids this
intersectional notion of justice that
you fight anti-semitism and all forms of
hate so you're particular and universal
and so it's animated this organization
for a hundred plus years
so in 2020 or 2021 when we incubated the
asian american foundation we did that
because at adl that's what we do
yeah
so to give people some background uh
some
prominent asian american leaders were
concerned about the
uh incidents of hate and people being
beaten and and in some cases even killed
and they called john
for advice
and then uh john
rolled his sleeves up and helped and
then helped
inaugurate the asian american foundation
which as an asian american
uh i'm immensely grateful but also think
wow like we haven't had something like
this until now i mean there was
something of a
void and it is
unfortunate that only when a community
feels itself to be
in the crosshairs or threatened uh in
terms of their family safety then they
gather together uh and try to make a
change yeah i mean i think you're right
on a couple fronts i mean i think
typically we
maybe it's human nature you know we take
for granted what we have like frogs in
the boiling water we don't realize
there's a problem
until it can be too late so i think
what's but what's again we get back to
what makes america great it's creating
this space and having a civic society
which is so kind of fertile and
conducive to people saying hey we need
to do something about this and doing
something about it i mean they the asian
american foundation they have raised
over a billion dollars in incremental
capital to fund aapi causes from
foundations foundations corporations you
know it's kind of mega donors it's
amazing what they're doing and you know
i think if adl and the jewish community
can share even a little bit of what
we've learned the hard way
to help the api community or again the
african-american community or whatnot i
think
you know i think that's a blessing
[Music]
so one of the most compelling stories
from your book that i found
engrossing was the story of a guy named
damian patton
and so damien patton is a
young jewish boy kind of lost soul
and then he winds up being radicalized
and joins a white supremacist group
uh even participates become something of
a young star and yeah
uh
and
it's obviously
um
something that people don't even imagine
possible
that where they didn't know he was
jewish yeah that's right and he was
concerned that he'd be outed as jewish
like he brought one of his
new friends home and then his mom's like
what the hell you're a skinhead you're
jewish
and then he had to deny it
um
so
i thought this story was so powerful and
humanizing because what it showed was
that this radicalization
uh can
prey upon or or it it it feels like a
human need that people have almost
regardless of background that's right i
mean i think
people yearn for community
right
especially that lost soul you know is so
eager to find a welcoming group where he
or she can fit in and in damien's case
he was from a broken home
didn't have strong role models found
himself kind of
attracted to gangs
first like latino gangs he had a friend
who was hispanic and then eventually got
pulled into the white supremacist
movement and it's extraordinary to think
that someone again could deny who they
were
and get pulled into something so toxic
and clearly like self-destructive but he
did
and not only did he get involved with
them he traveled from southern
california to tennessee
they committed a crime he was in the car
with two adults when he was still a
minor and they shot up a synagogue you
know thankfully no one was killed but
not for lack of effort
and uh they were arrested
and they were
arrested
indicted and sentenced but he was a
minor so as the two guys went to prison
he was let off and then he went on to
join the military moved found community
there eventually found he was pretty
good at coding
built a successful tech company
venture-backed on his way to an ipo in
the burgeoning tech scene in salt lake
city where there's some really some
interesting stuff happening and uh got
but got outed some investigative
reporter found out his past which damien
had never come clean about
and he was outed
and he was humiliated
and he was literally
fired from the company that he built
with his bare hands from the ground up
and relieved none of his
responsibilities the ceo pushed out
entirely by the board yeah so i think
this is really important because this is
about when you met him when he came to
your attention yeah so someone in their
distant past their adolescence
is affiliated or is a white supremacist
uh
serves in the military goes on to become
a business leader
uh years and years pass and then someone
produces uh records being like hey this
person
uh was a white supremacist yes it has
tattoos to that effect yeah um and so if
you just look at that headline you just
think well well this person's terrible
because you know like that they were an
active white supremacist uh meanwhile
uh this person had had like a completely
different life arc yeah you know and and
i mean he had a family yeah yeah which
happened obviously after he was long
after yeah long after and so then the
company looks at him and says well you
got to go because like we can't have
like a white supremacist founder uh you
know that that's going to like destroy
the company like where you know we're
trying to go public yeah um
and then he's looking at it like look
this is a part of my life that has
like not been a part of my life for
decades and decades yeah and so when you
were brought in to talk to him you know
like and it was one of the things i
admired about uh both
you know your account in the book um and
your work is that you
treated him like a human being of course
yeah i mean
i don't know that i deserve credit for
that i think that's the basic uh
what happened was
a friend of mine because you know i
worked in silicon valley for many years
who was a venture capitalist
jewish fellow
uh called me and said hey jonathan i
know this i'm an investor in this guy's
company
it's a crazy story would you talk to him
so first of all he had a valid
introduction from someone that i trusted
but i also called him because
like you know nick cannon who's a friend
has this phrase that he uses which i've
wholesale adopted
uh
and take credit for
uh he says he doesn't believe in cancel
culture he believes in council culture
and i think there's so much truth to
that so in damien's case
yeah he erred yeah he sinned but if you
like look i'm jewish i believe that
we're all created in god's image but
we're not god we're imperfect and we air
and we make mistakes
and the thing is can you learn from
those mistakes can you rep are you
willing to acknowledge the error
apologize maybe to those you've heard
and repent and so i called this fellow
and said it and look the first
conversation we had
we was a it was a phone call he was at
an airport in long beach
and he was basically speechless
i say i'm just calling to reach out let
you know i'm here i'm happy to talk to
you and then we got on a zoom like a
couple days later andrew and he was
glassy-eyed
and trying to make sense of what was
happening he just seen his reputation
uh destroyed and is his life completely
upended the whole his every exactly it
was like he was literally in a building
and the entire building was burning down
around him and he had no way out
and then
we talked again a week later and then a
week later and a week later and then the
weeks became months and the months
became years and i've talked to damien
not quite every week
but you know dozens and dozens and
dozens and dozens of weeks
and i did that because i've watched him
evolve and grow
not just you know what's the word like
not just externally
you know again from a white supremacist
who joins the navy who becomes a coder
and an entrepreneur and a ceo but like
internally as a person who's reckoned
with his past
and resolved himself to do better and i
i don't i think as head of the adl like
yeah i deal with big geopolitical issues
and whatnot but i also like i'm a human
being
and so helping him
find his path has been one of the most
rewarding experiences i've had in this
job
i think
council culture should be the new norman
standard 100 uh and it's one
uh one thing that i i admire about what
you advocate in your book
um which is that
look there has to be a path to
understanding or redemption
uh for people that want it i mean if
someone that's right
now that's really important like if you
are a serial offender if you are
unwilling to acknowledge
what you've done what you're doing
if you
will only listen to yourself in the
counsel of the people that you trust
rather than those who you've hurt like
that's a different story like i don't
have patience for people
who
you know continue to offend but if
you're willing to try
i think it's up to the rest of us to be
willing to help you
you know i don't know i should say that
for everyone but i think it's my job and
i think it's those of us in public life
andrew
can always do better
so
we talked about how there was this wave
of democratization and then it seems to
be reversing
uh and uh a woman
i spoke to recently barbara walter wrote
a book oh yeah that suggests a civil war
yeah that suggests that social media
might be part of
the reversal yeah that there is
something of a negative correlation
between
uh
social media adoption and
democratization which was a very
uh you know striking negative
correlation um you started
uh an anti-facebook campaign yeah um
that was the biggest most significant
effort i've seen yeah you got uh dozens
of
major corporations uh to get on board
what catalyzed that effort
so
first of all i would just recognize like
professor walter like she's a professor
at ucsd i really admire her scholarship
and her book is terrific
and i think there's something to what
she said about the pernicious role of
social media so when i joined adl you
know again i had worked in the valley
i'd worked inside google like i
understand these companies but i
was seeing how facebook was the front
line in fighting hate so adl opened a
center in silicon valley in 2017. i
think we're the first civil rights group
have a physical presence we were in palo
alto off university road yeah
and i and i didn't you know i didn't put
like some non-profit fundraiser to run
it i recruited a guy from reddit the guy
who used to be bp for revenue products
at reddit to run it so it's staffed with
software engineers and data scientists
and programmers and we engage on a
day-to-day basis with all the big
companies from from you know from amazon
to zoom from like from apple to youtube
google and instagram and of course
facebook we'll talk about that in
twitter and tick tock
we're working with the gaming companies
and the problems there are off off the
[ __ ] wall
go ahead man you can swear on this
podcast but they're off the wall uh
and the messaging platforms so we work
with all these different kind of arenas
but to the point that you were making
into what professor walter said
like there's no question that while many
of them and we work with them to
identify hate speech and help them
understand what extremists are doing the
toughest one to work with by far is
facebook wow i mean so we do and you met
with uh mark zuckerberg many times yeah
and look like there's a lot of good
people there who mean well i would say
that i have friends who work at baseball
sure but the kind of group thing that
happens there is extraordinary and
whereas a lot of the companies again
none of them are clean they're all have
their issues
but
we do an annual survey of online hate
and harassment doing it for years
the pla and the data's crazy
42 percent of people use social media
say that they've been on bullied online
28 percent this is our 2021 survey we
haven't done this years yeah
uh 28 it's probably worse 28 say they've
been systematically like continually
bullied on or stalked or you know
harassed online but the place where it
happens the most facebook it happens on
facebook three times as often as any
other platform
three times as often the instagram
numbers are terrible too
and while we've brought this stuff to
these companies again and again we had a
situation in the summer of 2020
right after the death of george floyd
where we were you know my analysts watch
the extremists i mean that's what we do
and we had extremes
they all do and lots of counseling but
we saw on facebook groups the extremists
organizing to disrupt the black lives
matter protests and we brought that to
facebook and they wouldn't do anything
about it i mean the highest value there
is really freedom of expression
but i don't think dude it's freedom of
money
[Laughter]
freedom of revenue but like you know
like my friend sasha baron cohen says i
don't think freedom of speech equals
freedom of reach but they've allowed the
lunatic fringe to go from the fringe
right into the mainstream
and so i reached out to derrick johnson
who runs the naacp
and to rashad robinson who runs a group
called color
we need to get organized and so we
launched this campaign we called it stop
paid for a problem that's right that's
right yes okay so you kick off stop pay
for profit which is a very audacious
campaign
uh and you do wind up with some major
corporate we had
i tell you what when we started the
campaign we said take we started it in
june
we said take the month of july off
facebook we told companies don't
advertise on facebook for the month of
july and when we started the campaign we
had we didn't have a single company
lined up and it was very audacious
um it's a little bit like my
presidential campaign
i suppose
three weeks later we had over 1100
companies the biggest brands in the
world incredible coca-cola mcdonald's so
why were they so deceptive do you think
like i'll tell you exactly why because
we gave them examples of like white
supremacist and anti-semitic and racist
content on facebook like flighted
against their ads yeah that's pretty
convincing so here's an amazon ad you
know next to a just like a bloody truck
that says let's go get the next george
floyd
or here's a sales force ad or a verizon
ad and so on and so forth
and you put that out there and howard
schultz says i don't want starbucks
advertising alongside the nazis but
that's what facebook was doing
and you know like i've talked to them
many times i had a conversation once
with mark and he said around all of this
i think maybe that's in the book and he
said you know jonathan a few years ago
all of the hate content on facebook was
user reported he said to me today 88
is is caught by our ai before users even
see it so i think we're doing pretty
good
and i was and i said okay well i used to
be an executive at starbucks we didn't
get to say 88 of our coffee doesn't have
poison in it so we think we're doing
pretty good
yeah especially if you imagine
the
number of messages they're talking about
i mean you have 12
out there 12 percent of an enormous
number is an enormous number yes that is
the law of large numbers it's huge
and
as much as we knew then i mean
the way we got the concessions all these
companies came off and then we organized
with sasha and leo dicaprio and selena
gomez the campaign to get celebrities
off instagram kim kardashian they all
joined us so for a week in august they
all got off the platform maybe they were
grateful not to have to post where we
yeah they were i did hear that i heard
people like oh my god thank goodness but
it also is important to them like it's
important to their brands so they engage
with their fans
so those two things led
facebook's okay we're actually ready to
talk and they did what we asked they
hired a vp for civil rights like we
asked they started classifying holocaust
denialism as hate speech like we asked
they took off white supremacist groups
like we asked they they released the
results of an audit they agreed to do an
audit i mean they did a bunch of things
it's not nearly enough
and you know i've heard people say well
what do you expect
and stuff is difficult
like the this is the most sophisticated
platform in the history of capitalism
yes they will earn
and 120 billion dollars this year like a
24 net margin
i mean yeah you know if the balance was
reversed where look they're making more
money
by getting that 88 up to
99.99 as opposed to less money like you
know they'd get it right you are
entirely correct like that's exactly the
right calculus so the problem is as
you're saying the incentives are totally
misaligned
there's no regulatory oversight because
there's a thing in the law called
section 230 and they have these written
before facebook
yeah like
1996 i think
and uh
you know i mean there's this hyper
libertarian ethos inside the company
and many of us might self-identify as
libertarians
but there's a problem when
that libertarianism involves again using
this product
and the product to literally not just
target
and stalk
but to you know cause physical harm to
people which we've seen happen
on facebook and on these other platforms
and you know the reality is all i would
say andrew to your point about the how
do you get it tonight what if it were
you know 99.9 increase the revenues they
took the nazis off
like
you know uh think about j j the big
pharma company so when they had a
tylenol scare in the 80s right where a
few bottles of tylenol were tampered
with in chicago
like
every freaking bottle off the shelves
every bottle off every shelf in america
and didn't put them back until they'd
reformulated or redesigned the packaging
and it turns out that was probably not
even like it wasn't even there they
could have argued like look this is not
something that we need to
you know respond to at this scale
correct
but they did that or i you know i used
to be in the beverage business we were
talking about that odwala is a you know
ready-to-drink juice brand and they had
a situation where one bottle in the bay
area this is in the 90s had it was it's
a non-flash pasteurized juice
so you can get you know things in it if
you will like bacteria and a toddler
drank a bottle of odolla
and got e coli and died it could be
lethal for a little kid terrible and so
what did odwala do they took every
bottle off every shelf in america
and redesign the production process
so
if odwalla can do it if j j can do it
literally one of the most innovative
companies in the history of business
should they should do whatever other
business does take the product off the
shelf and fix it like knock the nazis
off the platform like it isn't that hard
actually you know interestingly enough
and in a timely way there was an
announcement yesterday by facebook that
they are now allowing ukrainians to say
that they want to murder russians or
they want to kill putin you know they
said they are now allowing that because
of the war
like
i don't want mark zuckerberg deciding
what kind of hate speech is okay or not
okay
like you wouldn't allow
you you wouldn't allow a ukrainian to go
on
the uh i don't know on nbc or the new
york times right he wants to murder all
ukrainians like facebook should just
abide by the same rules the same kind of
standards that every other media
platform abides by it does really boil
down to mark doesn't it i mean what i
hear about that company is that it's
very very
centralized top down slash all the major
decisions get yet funneled through mark
now we're get now we get to like again
these broader issues you know
it may seem off topic but mark controls
64 some odd percent of the shares he has
these crazy class a shares give him all
the voting rights he's purged the board
of all the independent directors so
there's no fiduciary responsibility
there it's the mark show
and
that kind of power vested in one person
i don't know clearly it's not good
governance
vis-a-vis like the corporate world and
again i think invest the company is too
big and it has too much power in any one
person
yeah uh if i had won the presidency i
was going to to um
i was going to go to war with the social
media companies honestly because i just
didn't see a way that you could try and
bring the country together that didn't
involve
a very very significant overhaul of
their business practices and and
repeal section 230. make them liable
like every other business if you did
that and just that
now look it may create some there may be
some it would create some changes right
like maybe i wouldn't have as many a
restaurant would have as many you know
yelp ratings or something
but the reality is is
we can see the consequences of unbridled
unfettered
totally unregulated um
social media and we're living with the
consequences today
[Music]
so a significant portion of the book is
uh trying to guide people towards steps
that that they or we can take
and
that you make an argument that i think
most people appreciate that look there
are these attitudes and statements uh
and then there is a progression
where then that leads to actions that
ends up leading to that's right to
systems and then uh eventually it can
reach a point where the unthinkable
happens as it has happened in other
parts of the world yep so what can the
average person do if they want to
try to
keep
our country as free of hate as it can be
so i use the i use in the book this
construct we call the pyramid of hate
that you're referring to and it's this
notion that things can go from from bad
to worse to catastrophic
you know from biased attitudes
to prejudiced actions to systemic
discrimination to kind of acts of
violence to genocide uh
and i i mean we've got lots of examples
in history where this is what happens so
then the question comes well how do you
stop hate yes to yours so there's a
heuristic that we use at adl that i'll
share
it starts with number one speak out so
when you see hate happen speak out
and whether it's in your facebook feed
or like in the locker room or on
in the workplace on zoom or the water
cooler the dinner table like speak out
when you hear hate happen and you know i
to the earlier point of the conversation
like if you're a liberal speak out when
you hear progressives doing it if you're
conservative speak out when other
conservatives are doing it like our
ability to call out our people on our
own team
is really important and that's part of
how we depolarize here is acknowledging
again our own
kind of frailty
so number one you got to speak out
number two i think you got to share
facts
like this is what you do pretty well
we don't have enough of it there's too
much of a we have to dial down the drama
right like don't forward that crazy
email from your like mother's neighbor's
uncle you know who's a q anon enthusiast
and all the like we need less drama less
hysteria less hyperbole focus on the
facts and
talk to people
you know remember the golden rule of
doing doing to others right talk to
people like you want to be spoken to so
i think
sharing facts is really important and
then finally showing strength and for me
showing strength
is not just being an ally and showing up
for others that's part of it
it's honestly andrew it's like what
you've done it's leaning in and engaging
in democracy so whether you choose to
start a non-profit like venture for
america whether you choose to
run for office like you have done
several times
create a new political party and maybe
to those who aren't quite so ambitious
because you're pretty ambitious look
like go volunteer go run for the local
school board like go show up for the
library i mean like look
democracy is not a is not a foregone
conclusion no neither is it a spectator
sport you got to be in it to win it so i
think for me showing strength our job at
adl we would say
don't just lean in to fight hate lean in
to kind of create hope and build like
what dr king called the benevolent or
the beloved community that we all want
well
that that is the vision you know that
the struggles right now i mean we can
see it with
what's happening internationally in
ukraine you can see it in terms of the
surge
of
hate that you're
dealing with every day
talking about social media running amok
in part because our government
is asleep at the switch yeah in my
opinion yeah totally
we're in an era of kind of institutional
challenge institutional retreat yeah uh
and one of the big goals is like how the
heck can you
buttress institutions or reinforce them
in an era when people are just losing
faith and confidence in them right and
left uh and there are there are a couple
of things that i you know so there are
three things that you know that i try
to push people on and this is something
you and i are probably aligned on a lot
of this stuff so one it's okay let's
just try and make our institutions
better stronger number two would be to
try and modernize them um which we don't
seem to do enough of yes uh you know
it's like you have this ridiculous
antiquated section 230 that didn't
conceive of social media as like the
freaking
you know quasi uh
state that that that it is
like why aren't we tackling that and
then trying to start new
efforts or institutions that may be able
to earn people's trust
um but but this to me is like the
massive
uh
challenge of this era is that a lot of
institutions are coming into question i
think social media is part of that too
because you used to have this
uh curtain up where it's like hey you
know i you know let's say i was a ceo or
i was a public official you only see me
when i came on camera yeah
yeah but now now there's like this
peering behind the veil and it's kind of
brought people down and to some extent
that's positive because you're like okay
you know like humanized but then on the
other hand it's unfortunately really
hard for folks to feel like
um
like these institutions
have their best best interests at heart
because that they're uh you know seeing
differently in different ways um i i
can't help but think and when i was
reading your book i felt this it's like
i feel like
uh what adl
stands for wants to do
it's very
uh kind of
hand in hand with
successful institutions whether that's
families
schools
religious communities because it kind of
takes a collective to to lean in and say
like look uh there's no reason for us to
hate each other we're all human beings
yeah you know we all want what wanton
does totally deserve the same things
yeah i mean it's interesting as you lay
it out i i like i
deeply believe in institutions i do
i believe that
institutions tend to kind of develop and
evolve and accrete over time
they of course they can be
transformational in some things they can
be incrementalists and others but the
institutions are like the
like the tentpoles of our shared society
like they're crucial that doesn't mean
we leave them alone like we need to
continue to modernize and renew them
and yet at the same time we also have to
acknowledge when sometimes they're
inadequate like again a two-party system
that becomes so kind of corrupted by
special interests it doesn't create the
space for other voices to be heard and
that allows for a kind of capture
so it's interesting you think about
number one how do you take these
institutions which is so essential to
what we have and
modernize and renew them and at the same
time how do you acknowledge when we
might need to create the space
to reinvent those institutions the
democratic party the party are the
institutions i don't know but our
democracy institutions well they are but
they're also they're like edifices
democracy is the institution right the
elections are institutional and so
like i really appreciate what you've
done
uh and how you forced a conversation
that needed to be had and that i think
is far from over
well i i want to close with uh something
that i think you and i also see eye to
eye on which is that uh that we have to
do more to
de-radicalize individuals and and this
is one reason i admire your approach
where there's one thing you can say uh
is to
say for example
stop uh stop hating other people you
have various public awareness campaigns
but then there's the more difficult and
i would suggest uh more pressing work
where you actually get into
these groups and communities of people
that have been corrupted and subverted
by by hate and then bring them back yeah
um on the podcast and like gosh it was a
number of months ago now but i had
uh christian piccolini who started an
organization called free radicals uh i
feel like we have to be investing more
in those kinds of organizations
yeah i agree and i think we've gotta
recognize the fact that in an
environment where again social media
has allowed you know the fringe elements
to move and the extremists from the
margin into the mainstream
it's made it easier sure for many of us
to connect with old classmates and
family members in different places it's
also allowed these extremists to reach a
much broader audience than was ever
humanly possible
and
that extremism
whether it takes the form of you know
the anti-vaxx people or the q anon
crazies
or uh you know white supremacists
or radical anti-zionists these other
dangerous groups i think we've got to
create space
to bring people back so adl is very
committed to this work whether it's one
on one with someone like christian
piccolini who not sorry like damian
patton who's in the book yes christian
is a friend and i so admire what he's
done which is a very similar path to the
one that damien walked
um or someone like abdullah in tapley
who's in the book who who's grew up in
turkey
you know educated in that kind of
islamic system and learned to hate jews
and to hate israel in the jewish state
and then started to realize that it was
all a line of bs
and we actually meet people one-on-one
you realize they don't resemble the
stereotype and they don't hew to the
demonic image that's been created so
whether it can be de-radicalized from
extreme
you know white supremacy or extreme
islamism or any of the other dangers out
there anything that leads you to
dehumanize and yeah to dehumanize and
demonize other people um so we believe
in that work
i respect what christian has done there
are other groups like life after hate
which are doing really important work
something i think a lot about is how do
we help them to scale yes how do we give
them the support
the systems how do they use technology
more effectively so they can reach a
much wider audience because i could
counsel damien once a week you know for
an hour but there are so many damiens
out there if we could reach them and
find them i can't spend an hour a week
with every one of them
but i think there are ways we could help
you right now we have to force multiply
there because
and this is something that i would love
to see happen is that you take someone
like uh damien patton who uh now would
completely renounce all of the beliefs
that he held at that point of course um
the the problem is that there's still an
aversion to i think
um
working with people you've even had that
in their past
uh and if someone renounces that and
then wants to help others do the same i
feel like we should be
bestowing all sorts of resources on them
i mean i think about someone like
christian but it seems like could not
agree more
this is so important like
again if someone is willing to
take the risk
acknowledge their error put themselves
out there we should be embracing them we
should be lifting them up we should be
looking for ways to give them support
i think this matters enormously and so
we're really
really committed to that work
well john i couldn't believe it was your
first book but it was a great one uh it
could happen here why america is tipping
from hate to the unthinkable and how we
can stop it uh if we do stop it you're
going to be one of the big reasons why
thank you so much thank you for being
here thank you very much for having me
[Music]
you